Tucker cross and you may have heard of
this guy he's a fairly popular Cable
News host from what I understand he's on
a Fox News Channel I heard that
somewhere also he had a good take on
what sort of drives this what why does
this stuff keep happening here's Tucker
so just today Biden's top economic
advisor Cecilia Rouse addressed
reporters in the White House in the
briefing room about what had just
happened and she assured everybody that
the bank run we're watching is an
isolated incident
it's not big deal it's just this one
bank it's not connected to anything else
at all and the fact that this Bank
failed just like the fact that FTX
failed has nothing to do with the fact
that the people who run it spend a ton
of their time doing completely
irrelevant crap
that had to do with politics and
changing American culture
are you reassured by that well you
should know that Cecilia Rouse has been
thinking a lot about this when she
worked at Princeton which is a
university in New Jersey she wrote her
research agenda on
diversity equity and inclusion the title
is we're quoting diversity in the
economics profession a new attack on an
old problem svb and FTX for that matter
are just two of several major players in
the financial industry that have gone
under in recent months are you noticing
any of this
there was the bank silvergate more than
11 billion in assets there was a crypto
broker Voyager a billion in assets the
crypto fund three AC 10 billion in
assets block Phi and a number of others
on Friday Wells Fargo customer supported
they didn't get their paychecks as
expected the bank says that was just a
computer glitch we don't really know
okay so you got to understand Tucker is
reiterating the point that I've made
here several times once these companies
go in with this ESG nonsense so you
invest in companies not because they
produce something worthwhile or valuable
but because they have your social
justice nonsense Incorporated in them as
opposed to creating something good the
old days my God
I made the best little Dave Rubin in
town and I'm gonna sell them and then
the bank goes well how many uh you know
how many crippled children are you going
to save by saving your Dave Rubin by
putting out your Dave rubin's there they
go well little Dave Rubin Little Dave
Rubin I'm gonna sell a little Dave Rubin
for seven dollars a little Dave Rubin it
cost me three dollars to make little
Dave Rubin and I'm Gonna Keep the other
four and that's how it's going to work
and they go well what do you mean you're
not going to give a little money to
climate change for little Dave Rubin and
go Little Dave Rubin doesn't care about
climate change
foreign
I could have also done that with
chapstick but little Dave Rubin was
closer to me
but the point is guys this is what they
do this is what they do if you bring in
people what do you think that these
people at these Banks once you're in the
diversity Equity inclusion Department do
you think all day long they're focused
on my God we would like to invest in
good things we'd like to make some money
we'd like to really do right by our
investors or all day long are they
concerned that trans people are doing
this and gay people are doing this and
black people are doing this and
everything else
[Music]
thank you